so of course people see me as a man of
balance and even people inquire were you
born with his fabulous balance and i
agreen because actually to me it's work
it's a I was not born with with with
that talent I do not think so I think it
was a a lifetime of working on my
balance that made me acquire a very good
one
also the surviving feeling that you know
my balance saves my life but I extend
that to everything in life as much as we
need air and water and food we have this
force of gravity that nails us to the
surface of the earth and if we stand on
our two back legs as a mammal it's
because we we fought and we conquered
the balance now is very natural people
walk but actually walking is an art and
I can tell because I perfected the art
of walking on a tightrope for you know
almost 50 years now
and I find out that balance is not only
for workers for jugglers balance hits
you everywhere and balance in your head
is as important as balance in your in
your limbs if you are conscious of that
you know if you know it sounds silly but
if in the morning when you have
breakfast you don't slouch but you kind
of hold yourself not only erect you know
ready to to take decision for the day to
come but also perfectly balanced with
the feet parallel the hands you know
parallel as well and and eat your
breakfast that you will feel that is
little this little exercise so to speak
is gonna input and mark your entire day
you gonna feel better I mean look at
people sitting very rarely you will see
their feet parallel now I study martial
arts a little bit at some point and you
read a very interesting memoir from
Bruce Lee and Bruce Lee who actually
encompasses all the martial arts to
create his own were saying the human
attitude
to be able to spring into any kind of
action attacking defending dancing
walking is standing up erect you know at
ease with the feet parallel now you look
at people around sitting or standing up
I I swear that's so rare to see somebody
with parallel feet now what is that well
that is an image of balance of course
you see so experiments that force
yourself to be balanced and then you'll
see you'll you'll feel better